[Music]
Roseanne's Darlene Connor is all grown
up even greater
although the tenth season of Roseanne
was cut short with only nine episodes
airing actress Sara Gilbert proved in
that short time how much her and her
beloved character Darlene was the heart
and driving force of the series
sometimes you just gotta suck it up and
put your family first okay
major point Darlene Connor was at the
center of season 10 capturing the
struggles of a working-class woman in
today's America viewers were
reintroduced to Sara's character as a
single mom of two kids I don't think
we're trying to be anything or trying to
push the envelope I think we're just
trying to do what we do best the 43 year
old actress and not only initiated the
revival of the hit 90 sitcom and
reprised her role on the show she also
took on the task of co-executive
producer I'm not in boss lady I mean
really it's like you know I'm just lucky
that everybody said yes and you know
they gave me a title and Roseanne's
returned to primetime was historic
drawing at 10 percent more viewers than
the season 9 finale in May 1997 Sara
opened up to ET in May before the
cancellation of the series about the
incredible importance of her character's
return to television
quote she's become part of the cultural
conversation and she's such an important
face for a lot of girls who come up to
me and told me they hadn't seen anyone
like themselves on television and they
were so happy to connect with somebody I
feel a responsibility for their stories
in the 21 years between seasons 9 and 10
of Roseanne Sarah earned a graduate
degree from Yale created and continues
to co-host CBS's the talk became a
mother of three and married
singer/songwriter
Linda Perry Perry gushed over her lady
loves talent too
see back in 2015 amazing incredible
genius at acting yes I tell Sarah that
she was gifted with timing she has the
greatest timing I guess what do you call
that like when you deliver their
immediate timing oh my god
it's I'm I always when she like and she
does it all day long
you